so hello everyone my name is clinton
um i studied at
the at carnegie mellon university for my
bachelor's
degree in biological sciences
i did an honors degree there and i also
did two master's degrees
one in molecular medicine that's wet lab
research
and another one in dry lab research so
bioinformatics
i've learned several skills along the
way such as python
are linux programming and
i've won some awards in different
institutions
i also have a software engineering
diploma
and i do love i love both biology and
programming
so just a little bit about my background
my first masters was about studying a
protein known as
t20 like kinase or slk
and this was in a cancer lab
where we studied different cell lines
some mouse models essentially we were
working on characterizing
slk's role in apoptosis cell cycle and
cell migration
some common cancer phenotypes
and some things that we found out were
that it's critical
in normal development and a complete
knockout
lethal and it plays a role in
new induced memory tumor genesis
so um breast cancer in mice so that
could have a phenotype
a human phenotype for future projects
so these are just some results if you're
used to wet lab
techniques you might be familiar with
western blots
and focal adhesion assays so
the aim was to find out what slk do
the role of slk or c20 like kinase
in mouse embryonic fibroblasts by
testing
common cancer processes such as
proliferation migration and apoptosis
and finally the result was that
we noticed that focal adhesion turnover
seems to be impaired
so i did i studied this at the
university of ottawa
where i did my first masters
so after doing my white lab research
within a cancer lab i i felt
like i wanted to learn more analytical
skills
to analyze my data set so
looking at the trend around me i noticed
that
biology was heading towards a more data
science approach more uh where you have
to analyze different types of data
with more sophisticated software tools
so then i realized that let me
transition to
a more bioinformatics role and i joined
another masters immediately after my
first in
in the university of guelph so i did a
masters
in bioinformatics and some of the
reasons
why i did that was because of the the
changing dynamics of the field
my passion for both biology and
programming
i did get into computer science at
carnegie mellon for my bachelors
but at the time i was more interested in
biology
and i never really knew much about
bioinformatics or computational biology
so i because of that i got exposed to
different disciplines such as statistics
uh mathematics engineering computer
science
something that a person who just did
biology might not generally be exposed
to
so it did give me a lot of variety and i
didn't enjoy that so it was very
and i still enjoy it
so after doing my master's in
in bioinformatics um i i came across
i met ilya through one of his uh
interesting webinars and i he was
talking about his
bioinformatics for precision oncology
program and
we were discussing about the different
aspects
and um i i had the opportunity to
be one of the mentors for the program
i'm currently doing a teaching
and training of adult certificate
expected in august
so i do have the formal teaching skills
to embark in such a program and and it
was very
it was a very nice experience because i
have
i have the interest for cancer research
and it was very enlightening to see my
students with their own research
coming from a more wet lab approach
which is something i'm familiar with so
it was a very
i had the opportunity to talk to
research what lab research scientists
give them my
insights use the resources that we have
to
help improve their research by
incorporating important data science
techniques but for this program it was
particularly data science techniques for
cancer research
but the program that we're
talking about is more the important
software skills
for more generic types of research so
these techniques are very important and
being a person who
transitioned from a wet lab approach to
a dry lab
approach i can definitely appreciate
those techniques
and this was a fun experience and i hope
and i look forward to
repeating the same with you all
so that is does anyone have any
questions
so clinton i actually do have a question
for you
uh i'll represent the audience here
so my question is how difficult was it
to transition from learning about
life sciences and biology to data
science or to
you know other things that you've done
so
initially i thought it might be very uh
difficult um because there were some
uh programming concepts like like r
was a bit new to me i did a little bit
of python in
i did some python in my bachelor's
degree but it was minimal
i think with every new experience you
you kind of have
there's a learning curve so no matter
what you do you will have
some sort of learning curve and you
most people have to go through it um
thankfully
you know being in a good environment so
you know being in this course you'll
have experienced mentors to give you
that learning environment
just like my professors during my
master's program
so every i'd say in my experience
every challenge has a learning curve
it's preferable to have a good learning
environment and good mentors to help you
support
to support you during that learning
curve
and another question that i wanted to
ask was
how do you know when you've learned
something i mean how
many there are many resources online
right you can just download people's
code and you know try it and things
like that i mean how do you know that
you've actually learned
some analytical technique or method
so um because i
am i am in the process and i i have been
an instructor
uh there is a taxonomy it's called
bloom's taxonomy so there are different
levels
of learning so it depends on how
much depth you want to go into so you do
have a point that sometimes
you might not be sure if you learned
something and
educators like to use concept checking
questions
different types of assessment whether
it's
coding assessments or just
simple quizzes or multiple choice
questions
it's usually good to display your work
in a
in a project of some sort so
um that really shows that you've
mastered the
the tiny puzzle pieces in order to
create your own novel work
so that would be one of the higher
levels on that taxonomy
uh versus just you know typing a print
command
which just kind of shows you that you
you you memorize the recall so you have
that recall stage
so ultimately demonstrating
your work in a creative project that
would show like
your ultimate understanding so through a
research project
so whether that's publishing or doing
presentations
in front of other experienced people or
creating some manuscript or doing a
poster
so yeah okay great
thank you very much and if you do have
any other questions please do write them
in the chat box and we'll be sure to
address those
and i briefly want